ralph waldo emerson once
quoted that
nothing great can ever be achieved
without enthusiasm
i have a lot of enthusiasm
this is northlands in flemington new
jersey
northlands is the world's largest model
railroad
well i guess you know everybody has a
passion for something my thing was
trains had trains around the christmas
tree as a kid wherever i lived i'm
planning track plans and then over 18
years i added five basements onto the
house
from that i got fairly good at making
mountains and bridges and design work
and we decided to give it to the world
so we tore it all down bought this land
built northlands
any given day we run between 85 and 90
trains
some of the details in northlands inside
about forty thousand feet of track about
four thousand buildings
over four hundred bridges many of the
mountains in here are three and a half
stories high
most things in here are scratch built
underneath the entire superstructure
there's enough lumber to build about 42
large houses
it takes a few hours to go through for
the average person
to see everything
we went millions into debt
to build this place everybody thought we
were nuts the only one that believed
that what i wanted to do was my wife and
she was totally with me on this big time
it's an artistic endeavor
it's a gift to the world of what i can
do
and it makes
a lot of people happy
you